good afternoon as mr. Valda said my name
is Catherine sinkovitz I am from
Richland Michigan and it is my honor to
introduce our speaker this afternoon
Andrew Roberts is a historian and an
honorary senior scholar at GaN Ville and
Keys College Cambridge dr. Roberts is a
fellow of the Royal Society of
literature a trustee of the Margaret
Thatcher archive trust and a director of
the Harry Frank Guggenheim Foundation he
is the recipient of numerous book awards
including the Wolfson history prize the
intercollegiate studies institute prize
the Emory Reeves prize the British Army
Military Book of the Year award and a
history prize from foundation Napoleon a
regular guest on British and American
television and radio dr. Roberts writes
for The Sunday Telegraph The Spectator
literary review mail on Sunday and the
Wall Street Journal he is the author of
several books including eminent
Churchill Ian's Hitler and Churchill
secrets of leadership a history of the
english-speaking peoples since 1900
master and commanders how four Titans
won the war in the West the storm of war
a new history of the Second World War a
book which reached number 2 on the
Sunday Times bestseller list and
Napoleon a life which our speaker just
informed me has just been auctioned by
Harvey Weinstein for a TV series please
join me in welcoming dr. Andrew Roberts
ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
to be invited to address you today and
thank you very much indeed for those
kind words perfectly true that my book
got to number two and the bestseller
list beaten only by a book about Michael
Jackson the title of my talk
Churchill's early life is a deliberately
ambiguous rather dextrous one because it
allows me not only to speak about his
youth but also about his autobiography
my early life and the times review of
that book which appeared on the
publication day on the 20th of October
1930 mentioned not only the charm and
briskness of this book but also its
humor headlong excitement quiet irony
melancholy regret for vanished customs
and glories love of sport and the
pleasures of friendship although it also
made the slightly snide point that the
material is of course splendid as mr.
Churchill will agree the child is the
father of the man wrote William
Wordsworth and in many ways this is true
of Winston Churchill recalling that
great day on the 10th of May 1940 which
as was mentioned we've just celebrated
the 75th anniversary of the day in which
he became prime minister but also of
course the dreadful day that Hitler
unleashed his blitzkrieg on the West
Churchill wrote in his in his war
memoirs I felt as if I were walk-in with
destiny and that all my past life had
been but a preparation for this hour and
this trial and in a sense what I'd like
to do today is to look at his early life
and to look at the way that it was
indeed his youth was indeed a
preparation for the hour and the trial
of 1940 because it showed again and
again
the extraordinary leadership capacities
that he had the sheer character and
personality of the man shines through
again and again from the many different
vicissitudes that he face not just
physical but also moral vicissitudes now
clearly this is no rags to riches story
of the type so beloved by modern-day
biopics we're an outsider from nowhere
triumphs over the establishment or
anything like that he was the grandson
of the Duke and not just any old common
or garden Duke he was the grandson of
the Duke of Marlborough and so as I take
you through his life I'd like you to
keep in mind several things and many of
them mentioned in that Times Review in
fact the sense of humor the effect his
family life or the lack of it had on his
psychological development his powerful
sense of not having much time completely
absurd as it turned out in fact he lived
to be 90 but he didn't believe that he
had that much time and so therefore he
was always in a tearing hurry his
extraordinary lust for adventure his
intense competitiveness with his
contemporary and the contemporaries and
how incredibly accident-prone he was
with constants
near-death experiences when you go to
Dublin Castle
which I was there last week in fact and
you in the state apartments can see a
very large room which is decorated with
nothing but the paintings of former
Viceroy of Ireland almost all of them
British aristocrats in fact in the ten
years before and ten years after Winston
Churchill's grandfather the seventh Duke
of Marlborough was a Viceroy of Ireland
the post was held by two Dukes one
Marquess and three Earl's and Winston
Churchill lived there from the age of
two because his father Lord Randolph
Churchill was private sent that
secretary to his own father the the
seventh Duke and it was in a park in
Dublin around the age of four that
Winston Churchill was thrown from a
donkey in in
Ireland and concussed when they thought
they'd come across what they believed
was a Fenian demonstration but in fact
turned out to be a rout march of British
troops I was thrown off and had
concussion of the brain later Rose this
was my first introduction to Irish
politics it was his first introduction
but it was hardly life-threatening but
they were going to be many more
accidents to come one of the most famous
passages in my early life concerns his
mother Jennie Jerome the beautiful
daughter of a Brooklyn business tycoon
Leonard Jerome my mother always seemed
to me a fairy princess he wrote famously
a radiant being possessed of limitless
riches and power she shone for me like
the evening star I loved her dearly but
at a distance the untrue word in that
was always she was not a radiant being
much for him after he discovered that he
and his brother Jack Adam had their
inheritance from their father
misappropriated by Jennie Jerome but
instead because she was so distance
affection and love and surrogate
motherhood was provided by his governess
mrs. Everest a lady whose photograph he
kept by his bed for the rest of his life
and he also paid for the upkeep during
his life of her of her grave which I was
very proud at lunch today to discover
has been kept up after that by Richard
and Barbara langworth who were here in
the audience today
the first boarding school that he went
to some George's and asked at a skirt he
actually started to attend a month prior
to his 8th birthday so he went off to
boarding school at the age of 7 ladies
and gentlemen this is not child abuse I
know it sounds like it but my father and
grandfather and great-grandfather went
to boarding school at similar ages as
did I and say to my children ripping
children from their parents at attender
an impressionable age and handing them
over to sexually questionable total
strangers is not a primer facie case of
child abuse but something instead
that is called the British education
system some of Churchill's earliest
memories of some George's must be called
into question not least because he kept
referring to it as some James's in my
early life he made himself out to be a
dim child intellectually whereas his
school reports actually showed that he's
shown at some subjects like English and
history in Latin however his
contemporaries did far better than him
which seems to have led to a slight
sense of chipping us towards the
academically gifted especially those who
went on to read classics at Oxford and
Cambridge faced with an inability to
grasp the first declension he wrote
there was one thing I could do I could
learn by heart and his ability to
memorize huge amounts of verse and prose
stayed with him for life and would
astonish contemporaries many of the
occasions when he would quote reams of
poetry or old musical songs or speeches
from plays and he'd do it from memory
half a century after having learned them
how I hated this school he later wrote
and small wonder because in all the 12
years of his education no one ever
succeeded in making me write a Latin
verse or learn any Greek except the
alphabet and that some George's quote
two or three times a month the whole
school was marshaled in the library and
one or more delinquents were hauled off
to an adjoining apartment by the two
head boys and they're flogged until they
bled freely while the rest sat quaking
listening to their screams such beatings
usually but not always carried out
without overtly sadistic undertones were
immensely common in the British public
school system and indeed carried on
until the late 1970s as my own parts of
my own body can attest i've always since
noticed thou when supporters of capital
punishment confidently attest it never
did me any harm my private judgment is
always I'll be the judge of that such
beatings nearly broke Churchill's health
entirely and after a serious illness his
parents took him away in 1883 aged nine
he was transferred to a school in
Brighton kept by two ladies where he
stayed for three years
he nearly died from an attack of double
pneumonia but overall he was much
happier there where he could learn the
things that interested him in a happy
environment French history learning
poetry by heart riding swimming in the
Chapel Royal that Brighton that aged
about ten while the whole school turned
to the east when the Apostles Creed was
recited Churchill thought that the low
church mrs. Everest would consider that
a bluefish practice and I conceived it
my duty to testify against it I
therefore stood solidly to my front I
was conscious that having created a
sensation I prepared myself for
martyrdom however when we got home no
comment of any kind was made about my
behavior I was almost disappointed and
looked forward to the next occasion for
a further demonstration of my faith he
didn't get it because the following week
this school was shown to pews facing
east-west rather than north-south but
this was an early that's how it was this
an early indication of Churchill's
willingness to stand up for what he
believed in in net if necessary totally
alone or was it a deliberate perversity
combined with an element of showing off
as implied by his sense of
disappointment at the lack of official
response might the Anglican school not
have responded because they didn't want
to get involved in accusations of Anglo
Catholic practices with the transfer of
the accept Exchequer's son within a
decade of the highly controversial
public worship Regulation Act these are
matters for Churchill experts let none
say pedants such as Richard langworth
and Mary Ellen and myself to resolve in
1888 aged 13 Churchill entered Harrow
less than eighteen months after his
father's sensational resignation as
Chancellor of the Exchequer because of
his father's fame when roll call was
taken when he was in his first year at
Harrow with a name starting with s4
Spencer Churchill and in the bottom form
because of his low examination marks in
Greek and Latin he came at the very end
of the hundreds of boys filing past they
had master in the school yard coat large
numbers of visitors of both sexes used
to wait on the school stage
in order to see me March by and I
frequently used to hear the irreverent
comment why he's the last of all such
and humiliation could have had a
devastating effect on a lesser child but
for Churchill it was obviously a spur he
believed that by being put in the lowest
form at Harrow it meant I gained an
immense advantage over the cleverer boys
they all went on to learn Latin and
Greek and splendid things like that but
I was taught English the word splendid
in that sentence was clearly meant
sarcastically by the way though
Churchill employed sarcasm far less in
my early life in his other writings than
its far smarter cousin rich English high
irony his excellent English teacher
Robert Somerville taught him grammar I
learned it thoroughly thus I got into my
bones the essential structure of the
ordinary British sentence which is a
noble thing elsewhere he wrote I would
make them all learn English talking
about about school children and then I
would let the clever ones learn Latin as
an honor and Greek as a treat he was
joking again about the classics later
writing they told me how mr. Gladstone
read Homer for fun which I thought
served him right at Harrow Churchill won
a prize for reciting no fewer than
twelve hundred lines of Macaulay's lays
of ancient Rome without error this would
have been possible only if he were
utterly bound up with the tales they
told tales of heroism in the ancient
world an important influence on his
patriotism written by Harry masters such
as John farmer who wrote the music and
he Bowen who wrote the lyrics they were
intended to link the presents the pupils
present-day conduct and Cratchit ISM to
hairos and Britain's glorious past
articulating the strong continuum
between them thus the song states
Fortuna Domus of 1891 which was first
performed when Churchill was at the
school has a stanza that goes tonight we
praise the former days in patriotic
chorus and celebrate the good and great
who trod the hill before us where
Sheridan and peal began in days of Whig
and Tory where Ashleigh vowed to serve
the crowd
and Byron rose to glory in giants
another song that Churchill sang her Oh
viens were specifically enjoying to
remember that the hero race may come and
go that doesn't exactly die for all of
we whoever we maybe come up to the
giants of old you see thus his this
historical glory was not just something
to respect in all but to try to emulate
and even to better Churchill was not
therefore just in competition with his
contemporaries but he felt he was also
in competition with Sheridan Peale
Ashley and Byron on leaving Harrow his
father agreed to let him go into the
army for years I thought my father with
his experience and flair discerned in me
the qualities of military genius but I
was later told that he had only come to
the conclusion that I was not clever
enough to go to the bar Churchill had a
collection of toy soldiers ultimately
nearly 1,500 strong and he'd long been
fascinated by warfare moreover it was a
way that he could leapfrog those of his
contemporaries who were going to Oxford
and Cambridge but back to his accidents
in January 1893 visiting his aunt's Lady
Wimborne at Bournemouth he attempted to
jump the deep cleft lost his hold and
fell 29 feet from a bridge onto hard
ground he was unconscious for three days
in bed nearly three months he suffered a
ruptured kimrie kidney hemorrhage and
broke a bone in his mid-back which was
only discovered in an x-ray in 1962 for
a year I looked around at looked at
light round a corner he rose he was
lucky he looked at it at all and truly
extraordinary that he had achieved all
he did by 1962 with an undiagnosed
broken bone in his back it was in 1893
that Churchill met Arthur Balfour Joseph
Chamberlain Edward Carson Lord Rosebery
Herbert Asquith and John Morley the
great politicians of the Victorian late
Victorian era so soon as I was
convalescent I began to go to the House
of Commons and listen to the great
debates he rose he was present at the
most climactic debate in the 19th of the
entire
nineteenth-century Gladstone's winding
up at the second reading of the Irish
Home Rule bill on the 21st of April 1893
and in retrospect it's clear that the
early death of his father aged only 46
meant that Churchill who was 20 at the
time would be sure to enter politics one
day in June 1893 he qualified for the
Sandhurst cadetship in the cavalry on
his third attempt in my early life he
considered what might have happened if
he hadn't gone to Sandhurst making the
excellent joke that I might have
gravitated to the bar and persons might
have been hanged through my defence who
now nursed their guilty secret
complacency he entered the cavalry
because it offered easier entry than the
more intellectual or less unintellectual
infantry and artillery besides as he
wrote the uniforms were much more
magnificent his father was unimpressed
and quote I received from him a long and
very severe letter expressing the
bleakest view of my educational career
showing a marked lack of appreciation of
my success in examination and warning me
of the danger in which I plainly lay of
being a social wastrel it's hard to make
Lord Randolph Churchill ladies and
gentlemen out to be much more than a
harsh Victorian father that summer
Churchill and his younger brother Jack
went on a walking tour of Switzerland
and they climbed the Vetter horn and the
monterosso mountains he also knit not
the kind of thing the one does that
social wastrels necessarily do he was
also nearly drowned at Lake Lausanne
when he and his brother Jack who he
curiously only refers to as a younger
companion in his autobiography went
swimming and a breeze picked up and then
sailed away the boat faster than he
could swim towards it bang in the middle
of Lake Zurich Lausanne he was facing
yet another brush with death and this
time he even gave it a color I saw death
as near as I believe I have ever seen
him he later wrote he was swimming at in
the water
at our side whispering from time to time
in the rising wind which continue to
carry the boat away from us at about the
same speed we could swim no help was
near unaided we could never reach we
could never reach the the what's the
thing by the survived on the edge of
lakes the shore to everything I've got
the floor here unaided we could never
reach the shore
I now swam for life I scrambled in and
rowed back for my companion who though
tired had not apparently realized the
dull yellow glare of mortal peril that
had so suddenly played around us in
spring 1894 it became clear to everyone
that his father was gravely ill of
course no medical diagnosis of his
illness was offered by Churchill in my
early life who himself believed along
with most other people at the time that
it was syphilis although several
historians today believe instead it was
a rare disease of the brain of his
father he wrote in a line surely as
autobiographical as biographical he
embodied that force Caprice and charm
which so often Springs from genius in
June he said goodbye to his father as
his father went off on a round-the-world
tour he patted me on the knee in a
gesture which however simple was
perfectly informing I never saw him
again except as a swiftly fading shadow
all my dreams have comradeship with him
of entering Parliament to decide and in
his support were ended they remained for
me only to pursue his aims and vindicate
his memory the previous November
Churchill had become twenty years old
writing later
22:25 those are the years don't be
content with things as they are you'll
make all kinds of mistakes but as long
as you're generous and true and also
fierce you cannot hurt the world or
seriously distress her she was made to
be wooed and won by youth on the 20th of
February 1895 he was commissioned into
the Queen's 4th Queen's Own huzzah as a
second lieutenant I had the ill luck to
strain my tailors muscle that the
Sartorius muscle it's the longest muscle
in the in the body it's the one that
goes down the thigh on which one's grip
on a horse depends in consequence I
suffered tortures galvanic treatment was
then unknown one simply had to go on
tearing at a lacerated muscle with the
awful penalty of being thought of boobie
if one begged off even for a day the
physical courage ladies and gentlemen of
Churchill it equals his his moral
courage which is rare in the closing
decade of the Victorian era the Empire
had enjoyed so long a spell of almost
unbroken piece he wrote that middles and
all they represented an experience and
adventure were becoming extremely se
scarce on the British Army as so often
it was the honesty of my early life that
gave ammunition to Churchill's
detractors he was accused of being a
mere medal hunter with this sentence
often held up as evidence but the key
wording is all they represented in
experience and adventure war service was
the path to distinguish story
distinction he wasn't rich enough to
maintain hunters as well as polo pet
ponies his father Lord Randolph was the
younger son of the Duke and so instead
of being able to afford to do this he
took the decision to use his ten weeks
leave to visit the Cuban Civil War
joining the side of the Spanish captain
general Marshall Martinez Campos he went
there via New York writing to his mother
on the 10th of November what an
extraordinary people the Americans are
their hospitality is a revelation to me
and they make you feel at home and at
ease in a way that I've never before
experienced it's good that some things
don't change you might call it
tomfoolery he also wrote to travel
thousands of miles with money one can
ill afford to get up at four o'clock in
the morning in the hope of getting into
a scrape in the company of perfect
strangers is certainly hardly a rational
proceeding the 10th the the 30th of
November was my 21st birthday and on
that day for the first time I heard
shots fired in anger
and heard bullets strike flesh or
whistle through the air that's half true
ladies and gentleman in fact it was the
next day on the day itself he might have
heard bullets fired in anger but he
didn't hear them whistle through the air
there's a new book by hands clip hack
about precisely this this period in
Churchill's life but certainly on the
1st of December whilst eating a chicken
outside a place called Arroyo Blanco
which is right in the center of Cuba at
which I visited in fact in May of this
year
Churchill heard a ragged volley rang out
from the edge of the forest the horse
immediately next to me not my horse gave
a bound it had been shot in the ribs and
as I watched these proceedings I could
not help reflecting that the bullets
which had struck the chestnut had
certainly passed within a foot of my
head so at any rate I had been under
fire that was something nevertheless I
began to take a more thoughtful view of
our enterprise than I had hitherto that
night not only shots but volleys were
resounded through the night a bullet
ripped through the fatch of our tent
another wounded and wounded and oddly
just outside I fortified myself by
dwelling on the fact that the Spanish
officer whose hammock was slung between
me and the enemy's fire was a man of
substantial physique indeed one might
have called him fat I've never been
prejudiced against fat men at any rate I
didn't grudge this one his meals of the
fighting the next day he said there were
sounds about us sometimes like a sigh
sometimes like a whistle and at other
times like the buzz of an offended
Hornet he returned from Cuba with three
things that stayed with him for life his
love of cigars of siestas and being in
the thick of wherever was the most
important thing happening at the time in
october 1896 he to the Sassoon dock in
bombay harbor in in india modern-day
mumbai he sure enough had another
accident we came across alongside a
great stone wall with dripping steps and
iron rings for hand holds he days rose
the boat rose and fell four or five feet
with the surges I put out my hand and
grasp it as a ring but before I could
get my feet on the steps
the swipe the boat swung away giving my
right shoulder a sharp and peculiar
wrench a scrambled Apple right
made a few remarks of a general nature
mostly beginning with the early letters
of the alphabet hugged my shoulder and
soon thought no more about it yet in
fact his dislocated shoulder an end that
I had sustained an injury which was to
last me in my life in which was to
[ __ ] me at polo to prevent me ever
playing tennis and to be a grave
embarrassment to me in moments of peril
violence and effort once it nearly went
out through a too expensive gesture in
the House of Commons yet it wasn't all
bad news because keep had he been able
to use a sword at the Battle of Omdurman
rather than a Mauser pistol my story
might not have got so far in the telling
he philosophized in my early life when
you make a mistake it may very easily
serve you better than the best advise
decision life is a hole and luck is a
hole and no part of them can be
separated from the rest it
extraordinarily ladies and gentleman he
wrote that in 1930 the very year before
he resigned from the Tory front bench
which allowed him to be out of office
during the wilderness years and thus
unsullied by any collective
responsibility for a peace mode in the
winter of 1896 the desire for learning
came upon me he liked the feel of words
fitting and falling into their places
like pennies in a slot he wrote he
hadn't been to Oxford or Cambridge but
claims not to have been chippy about it
we never set much store by them all
they're affected superiority he said of
people who did go to Oxford and
Cambridge remembering that they were
only at their books while we were
commanding men and guarding the Empire
now I pity undergraduates when I see
what frivolous lives many of them lead
in the midst of precious fleeting
opportunity after all a man's life must
be nailed to the cross of either thought
or action I'm not convinced about this
that he that he didn't mind about the
affected superiority of people who went
to Oxford and Cambridge there are so
many slighted references to them but
nonetheless his
walkabout guarding the Empire obviously
didn't matter to him deeply because you
can't have Churchill without Empire I
was very pleased to see Larry on in his
in his excellent book Churchill's trial
puts the Empire in the middle there with
with war and peace central areas of the
book because Winston Churchill for not
just for Britain and also of course for
democracy but also he fought for the
Empire and although it's not very
popular at the moment the British Empire
was absolutely epicentral to his to his
entire outlook all through the long
glistening middle hours of the Indian
Day I divided given he wrote and then
after that Edward Gibbons autobiography
and then Macaulay but Churchill was
shocked by Macaulay's history primarily
because it was harsh about the first
Duke of more Brown and was it from
Gibbon that he got his religious
agnosticism or from Winwood reads but
the martyrdom of man which argued that
all religions were essentially the same
and and which denied the divinity of
Jesus the remark he made about
church-going was that at Harrow there
were three services every Sunday
besides morning and evening prayers
throughout the week all this was very
good I accumulated in those years of so
fine a surplus in the book of observance
that I have been drawing confidently
upon it ever since
in India Churchill and displayed what he
called ace extraordin he was able to
read all this Gibbon and Macaulay and
all the other people we also read
Schopenhauer and Leckie and the great
thinkers of the day and because you also
suffered from what he called complete
absorption in with the game of polo
he played nevertheless than eight and
more often ten or twelve chuckles of
polo polo a day and never in the history
of Indian polo had a Cavalry Regiment
from southern India he was based in
Bangalore and
yeah one the interim ental cup yet they
won that and his regiment the fourth
desires one that even though Churchill
had to play with his arm strapped to his
side out of pain from his from his
injury their dislocated shoulder just
Chile extraordinary not least of course
that he also scored the winning goal he
was staying at Goodwood Park which is
one of the Great's stately homes of
England the house of the Duke of
Richmond and he was on leave when he
read of the pithan revolt on the
northwest frontier and he immediately
got himself attached to the new force
that was being sent it was being got
together there that Malik and field
force and it was there that he learned
to drink whiskey I've been brought up
and trained to have the utmost contempt
for people who got drunk
except on very occasional exceptional
occasions and a few anniversaries he
wrote and I would like to have had the
boozing scholars of the universities
wheeled into line and properly chastised
for their squalid misuse of what I must
ever regard as a great gift of the gods
Churchill was incredibly politically
incorrect to modern ears it it has to be
said there's a there's a passage in the
in my early life in which he says we had
the very strong spirit of the diehards
and the young bloods of the enemy they
wanted to shoot at us and we wanted to
shoot at them so a lot of people were
killed and on our side the widow's have
had to be pensioned by the imperial
government and others were badly wounded
and hopped around for the rest of their
lives and it was all very exciting and
for those of us who didn't get killed or
hurt very jolly on a punitive expedition
in the Malakand field force among the
mud villages of the mamonde
valley Churchill found himself with five
British officers and about 85 Sikh
soldiers when in an area that had seemed
totally quiet suddenly the mountainside
sprang to life swords flashed from
behind rocks bright flags waved here and
there a dozen widely scattered smoke
puffs broke from the ragged face in
front of us loud explosions resounded
place
from high above us on the crag 1,000
2,000 3,000 feet above us white or blue
figures appear dropping down the
mountainside from ledge to ledge like
monkeys down the branches of a tall tree
a shrill cry arose from many points and
then moments later the British officer
who was with him was spinning round just
behind me his face a massive blood his
right eye cut out yes it was certainly
an adventure it was a point of honour
not to leave wounded men behind death by
inches and hideous mutilation the
invariable measure meted out to those
who fall in battle into the hands of the
Pathan tribesman so in the course of
saving this officer this wounded officer
five Britons and Sikhs including
Churchill went back to bring him back
whereupon one of the sikhs was shot
through the calf and Churchill got away
got him back by dragging him along by
his collar to safety and Churchill had
risked his life therefore to save the
soldiers in the same action the
regimental adjutant was cut to pieces
with a sword and Churchill was so keen
to avenge him that he almost got cut off
by the enemy I looked around I was all
alone with the enemy not a friend was to
be seen I ran as fast as I could
there were bullets everywhere I got to
the first null hurrah the Sikhs were
holding the lower one yet another place
brush with death ladies and gentlemen
and the chance to show character and
leadership but also the judgment to know
when to run like hell
such brushes with death were to be
repeated wrigley thereafter not least in
a cavalry charge at the Battle of
Omdurman his attempt to save an ambush
trained in the Boer War his escape from
the Boer prisoner of war camp in
Pretoria and so on and so on
yet Churchill didn't crave excitement
for itself like some kind of extreme
sports junkie today rather he knew that
he needed the attention and medals that
came with it in order to leapfrog his
contemporaries especially the cleverer
boys if he was to attain his dream of
vindicating his brilliant stricken but
distant and often disdainful father he
needed Fame and he needed it on his own
terms
humor headlong excitement quiet irony
melancholy regret for vanished cousins
and glories love of sport the pleasures
friendship that anonymous Times reviewer
of my early life was uncannily accurate
both about the book itself and about
what actuated Winston Churchill when he
came to the Premiership in May 1940 aged
65 it was as a fully formed leader
possessed of all the attributes and
personality traits necessary for this
hour and this trial extraordinaire only
though almost all of these they're not
of course the political experience that
was also necessary he had attained
before the absurdly young age of 25
thank you very much indeed
so we have plenty of time about 20 or
minutes or so for questions from from
anyone other than Richard langworth if
you put your hands up this this lady in
this gentleman again to give you the
microphone please don't feel constrained
just to ask questions about his early
life I'll try and ask questions about
wider thing as well I've read that book
many times and the one thing that
puzzles me is Churchill has a younger
brother and we never hear anything about
the younger brother tell us about Jack
um yes that's right he is mentioned of
course but he's not a central figure and
he did actually cut him out of that
Lausanne incident and and didn't mention
that it was his brother whose life he
had been put in danger and by jumping
off the boat Jack was a brave man in his
own right he fought in the Boer War he
was Gallipoli he was put on into the he
got onto the staff on the Western Front
he became a stockbroker
he loved his brother daily they were
they were extremely friendly and close
but he was not I think it's fair to say
an essential figure in the Churchill Ian
cannon he wasn't one of the the true
intimates in the way that Bracken or
breva Burke or or the Prophet Linderman
or any of those other people were and so
it was a it was a happy fraternal
feeling that he had towards his brother
and that his brother had towards him his
brother was very proud of his
achievements but he didn't take advice
for example from from his brother but he
was good to his brother when it came to
finances family finances and everything
they
he was he's very decent and an honorable
as he diffict it hi alex Bookman I'm a
senior here at Hillsdale for many of us
Churchill is a hero we have a statue of
him obviously at Hill cell I was
wondering who did Churchill look up to
in his early life would that be through
reading and it was it
I guess people in in antiquity or even I
guess his I guess superiors during his
time in the military well of course the
primary one was his father and he took
many of his much of his political
philosophy that he kept for the rest of
his life from his father's concept his
father really was the inventor of the
concept of Tory democracy trust the
people and that was something that the
Churchill stated Churchill very much for
the rest of his life and he admired when
he when he grew up he he admired
Benjamin Disraeli but he was only seven
when Disraeli died he remembered
Israelis death very very well and
mentions it in my early life really
though it's the it's the first you cook
more bruh his great ancestor who was the
victor in the war of Spanish Succession
which was he was the greatest soldier
along with the Duke of Wellington who's
the greatest soldier in the history of
the British Army and and so he was an
ultimate hero for Winston Churchill and
several more the Admiral Nelson and and
Drake who he was related to very
distantly these were the giants of
British military history also Oliver
Cromwell and he tried to have a ship
named after Oliver Cromwell but failed
when King George the fifth wouldn't put
up with it
understandably so considering and the
chroman was a regicide but nonetheless
it would have been 300 years also
earlier
he was very very well-versed in all of
the laser ancient Rome the the great
great ancients know that but these were
the stories that he grew up with and as
I say he was able to recite twelve
hundred lines of Macaulay's ancient Rome
it's a it's a it's a wonderful I do
recommend it I haven't read the whole
thing from comfort of cover I admit but
the bits that I have read and was forced
to learn at school are still pretty
pretty magnificent and moving I was
wondering if you could say something
about his the marriage to Clementine yes
well it thank you madam it doesn't crop
up except for the last sentence of my
early life where he said that he got
married and lives happily ever after but
that's that's pretty true that's what
happened he he married a very remarkable
and impressive lady in Clementine that
Churchill who looked out for him she
didn't like all of his friends which is
perfect and because several of them must
have been extremely difficult people to
have got on with but nonetheless she
provided the domestic stability that he
needed love and affection for children
and a home life in which he could which
he knew that he could sally forth out to
the House of Commons night after night
very Rick very Wrigley the House of
Commons wouldn't break up until midnight
and so you know it that kind of thing is
incredibly tough on on family life but
there's no indication that it was too
tough on his she was a very impressive
remarkable woman during the Second World
War she helped the the Red Cross aid to
Russia funds with the helped the the Red
Cross aid to Russia funds which in
factually ladies I think
which was important and all in all there
there isn't a sort of whiff of
negativity I think all deadly and
scandal about a very remarkable woman
what role did Winston Churchill's
grandparents play in his early life his
grandparents played pretty pretty small
role he was the seventh Duke was the
Viceroy of Ireland as I say so he was a
he was a sort of extremely grand figure
but he ritual tell me the age at which
he died Churchill's age when when when
the Duke died but I think he was fairly
young wasn't he when that when the Duke
died so it wasn't too much of a of an
effect but the next Duke the eighth Duke
Sonny became a great friend of was a
great friend of Churchill's and of
course Blenheim was a place that
Churchill always felt was almost the
second home to him and it was at
Blenheim that he proposed to to
Clementine to go back to the original
earlier question but more importantly
this moral connection was vital to him
for two reasons
and the first was that the Spencer
Churchill name is one of the grandest
and most aristocratic in Britain and
therefore gave him a standing an
automatic standing in society which also
gave him the kind of confidence that
would be needed in order to take all
these risks and all with embark on all
these adventures and and the second
thing was that because of the history of
her to go back to the question for that
his great ancestor the first Duke this
giant of British military history he
also felt he had a lot to live up to and
so it was a name in a sense rather like
that phrase about about the Bonaparte's
that about Napoleon the third his name
was both his making and his undoing
Winston Churchill's name could have been
it was part of the making but also could
have been
the undoing if he hadn't managed to to
live up to it as it is of course he
lived up to it and and even put it in
the shade could it be in sir my question
is about Churchill's personality he's
often described by several of his
advisers as temperamental I was
wondering if you would comment on his
own personal leadership style and how it
affected his conduct of a war yes he was
indeed deeply temperamental and not
least this is evidenced by the fact he
kept bursting into tears he was the most
lachrymose Prime Minister we've ever had
there are some 30 occasions during the
Second World War when when he is his
described as having tears in his eyes
and this is because he's a Regency
figure he's not some stage lately Lake
Victoria he's actually a throwback to a
much grander and earlier past actually
at the funeral of Lord Nelson every
single one of the eight Admirals that
carried his coffin they were all in
tears men allowed their emotions to to
show in the Regency period in a way that
they simply didn't in the late Victorian
period so yes he was temperamental he
could he could shout at meetings and
bang his fists and he would be immensely
toffee would keep his chiefs of staff
out till two or three or sometimes four
o'clock in the morning and it was it was
you know hard work for those around him
but he was trying to win a world war and
so you know that's perfectly understand
we was trying to get his way and he used
every every part of his personality to
do that including his fabulous sense of
humor there was one moment when Anthony
Eden his foreign secretary was asking in
a cabinet meeting what they could
possibly do about Turkey this was in
November 1943 they were desperate to try
and get turkey into the war and
and Turkey was resolutely neutral and
and had been since the beginning of the
war four years earlier and the question
was with did they try to cajole Turkey
did they try to threaten turkey did they
try to bribe Turkey how could they get
turkey into the war and at the end of
this very hard-fought cabinet meeting in
which the in which all the different
points of view were put forward with
great gusto by by the people who were
presenting them and Winston Churchill
said tell dirky that christmas is coming
among those whom church of greatly
admired some of whom you spoke of
earlier do you think he admired Napoleon
undoubtedly he hugely admired a podium
which is very unusual for an English
story of course who who basically
English tourists think of Napoleon as
another philip ii of spain kind of
dictatorial figure who wants to invade
us and therefore a bad thing Churchill
on the other hand made endless
references to Napoleon in the in the
House of Commons in his speeches none of
them negative he was a he in his private
library he has no fewer than 160 books
about Napoleon that he had found in his
own by his own leather binder he wanted
to write a biography of Napoleon and in
the 1930s and never got around to it he
wrote history of the english-speaking
peoples instead and he wanted also to
write a film script about Napoleon which
would have been one of the fabulous
things to have to have seen or in your
case maybe to have acted any it would
have been really something but no he did
atmanah Polian and one can see why there
are overlaps between the personalities
the capacity for the
compartmentalization of his of his mind
Larry on refers to this in his book
Churchill's trial the way in which
Churchill was able to fasten on to a
problem and concentrating on it to the
exclusion of everything else until that
problem was was settled in his mind is
something that also you see in the Pony
in a great deal Winston Churchill was
always considered such a great speaker
but yet I had read that he had a speech
impediment particularly when he was
younger what methods did he use to
overcome that to really become such a
great orator um well he he did have a
sibilant
a sibilant emphasis where s's became sh
a--'s when he was younger you you hear
much much less of it as his career
progresses this isn't because he went to
a speech therapist there are some
stories about him speaking with stones
in his small stones in his mouth I
haven't seen any any collaborative
evidence of that have you Richard no no
I think it's practice it was just simply
the extraordinary amount of time that he
would practice he would memorize these
great long speeches in his early years
and then he would use Psalm form it was
called the way that they were printed
out on his typed out on his sheets of
paper little 6 by 4 inch cards that he
would use and he would sometimes spend
as many hours practices of speech as
there were minutes in the speech and
it's a extraordinary thing he would
march backwards and forwards often to
the sound of marching music on the on
the gramophone and would would rewrite
the speech right up until the last
moment just before he he stood up and
gave it you can see the annotations to
the speech within his handwriting at
Churchill College Cambridge I really do
recommend you do that if you have a
chance when next to in England but there
it was he understood you in his only
novel severally
which was published in 1900 he wrote
about the power of oratory how important
the power of oratory was and how it was
capable of of working for people even
even at the lowest point when no one
will is following you at least if
they're still listening you have a
chance and of course that chance was put
to incredible effect in the campaign
against appeasement in the 1930s and
then again of course uniting the nation
in 1940 standing with Allen packwood
holding a document at Churchill College
Cambridge is indeed one of the thrills
of life I have a question about destiny
and you mentioned Churchill's quote from
World War two the night he became Prime
Minister felt as if I were walking with
destiny he also told Merlin Evans when
he was I think about 15 about his
feeling of destiny do you recall that
one where he's a student where what what
about this destiny that Churchill felt
and it was evidently replete throughout
his life could you speak to Churchill's
vision and his and his feelings for
destiny yes it's another very good
question and he had a very powerful
sense of his own destiny and but I think
as I mentioned with through Gibbon and
Winwood read and then Leckie indeed he
was not a Christian he didn't believe in
the divinity of Christ but he did
believe in in fate in Providence and in
an almighty he refers to the old man he
with a capital H he prayed to God when
he was on the battlefield
so there was obviously a religious sense
a spiritual religious sense with regard
to a divinity that was out there but
when one looks at it it doesn't it
doesn't seem that God had many other
jobs except for taking care of Winston
Churchill and and yet it was he never
got to the point that such as I'd like
Adolf Hitler did after the July plot in
1944 where he felt that his own will
could over could even sort of over
command that of Providence or destiny
you know he knew that he was the he was
the servant of Destiny rather than its
master
this wasn't a sort of insane feeling at
all but it was one actually that I think
that quite a few politicians probably
even today do have and and I think it
was important for him when in the First
World War he just left a trench dug out
in order to see his general and moments
after he left
a German whiz-bang high-explosive shell
hit the dugout he was standing in and
killed everybody inside it decapitated
his Batman etc he put it down to two to
Providence we have time for one more
question could you say something about
Churchill's early interest or training
in science or the lack thereof and
whether that played a role in his close
relationship with Professor Lindemann
regarding matters like the atom bomb for
example yes he he was good at chemistry
actually it at Harrow he discussed and
was interested in physics but didn't I
mean read about physics but wasn't
examined in it or anything like that but
when but very very early on he I think
it was at 1923 or 1927 he wrote about
the importance of the splitting of the
atom and its possible military use and
that was and his interest in physics
also as you as you allude was at the
heart of his friendship with or the
Oxford professor of physics professor
Lindemann later Lord Charles who was far
and away during the war far and away the
closest of his friends to him I've just
been to checkers the Prime Minister's
country house and the Prime Minister
very sweetly allowed me to spend a
couple of hours looking at all the
people that the names in the visitors
book of all the people who who visited
checkers during the Second World War and
then later after the war as well but I
was particularly interested in the 1942
45 period during his first Premiership
and Lord char wall turned up pretty much
every single weekend that Winston
Churchill was there far far more than
pretty much all of the other close
advisors of his put together it's a he
couldn't but have had he didn't have an
influence on Church what nobody had an
influence on Churchill Churchill made up
his own mind about everything but he
certainly had
and input that was that was second to
none and they did discuss matters of
physics which were so important during
the Second World War when one thinks of
the of the the beans that Ray beans the
importance of radar the as you mentioned
the atomic bomb
you know Churchill had to be well up on
all of these latest developments and and
he was that was the last question but I
just like to repeat especially for you
young people here that that fabulous
line from my early life and take it to
heart please where he says 20 to 25
those are the years don't be content
with things as they are you will make
all kind of mistakes but as long as
you're generous and true and also fierce
you cannot hurt the world or seriously
distress her she was made to be wooed
and won by youth thank you very much
indeed